[Music]
with these events like the hope is to
sort of say and there are these things
around you and what better way to do
that than to have the actual event in a
place that kind of illustrates that idea
so you know Bowman's a great treasure I
mean it's such a great treasure
obviously that now it's like literally a
national you know a monument
[Music]
we do find especially with this book
that people first look for where they
live or a place that they're familiar
with to see if they're if they know
about what's in the book and so much of
the time we find that we Surprise them
which is so satisfying because that's
one of our goals is to show people that
there is something just down the road or
20 minutes away that they had been
nervous never seen or I've heard about
but never quite made that track to go
there Lizzie Borden breakfast at the
hotel we are a guide to the world's
hidden wonders we focus on trying to
find amazing beautiful strange wondrous
places all over the world
and that can mean a million different
things I mean it can be a tiny museum
that someone's dedicated their life to
curating in their own idiosyncratic
fashion it can be a great story from
history it can be a natural wonder even
an industrial disaster like the gates of
hell I mean there are places hopefully
that have some aspect some element to
them that is surprising and even sort of
outside of what you thought was sort of
possible in a sense and then I think the
hope is that in kind of collecting these
things together you expand people's
sense of what's possible what's even you
know could be out there and also
hopefully we remind people that these
things are out there and they're not all
far away they're close by and you serve
the whole thing hopefully is a kind of a
nudge to people to get out into the
world and explore for themselves
[Music]
she doesn't sing
she just doesn't see
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys those are the best cause I've
ever had